hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go
subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos as they come out
yeah do it welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is
are you garbage the show we sit down
with your favorite comedians and find
out if they grow up classy
or if they're absolute trash i'm your
host holy coming at you on a beautiful
day
down here aunt toddy's basement she uh
she was on her way back from washington
yes
so people came to the door this morning
and now i'll see her
on tuesday at the arraignment sure my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me
he uh he's the the ceo of ru garbage he
cooks the books he keeps us all in line
gang the next time you're reaching for a
best pal do yourself a favor
make it a kippy give it up for kevin
james ryan hey what's up everybody first
of all thanks for tuning in please make
sure you rate review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube
and then obviously patreon.com join that
[ __ ] army of garbage baby help us
keep the lights on
wet our beaks a little bit we got bail
money to cover
uh yeah if you join we will uh answer
one of your garbage questions on there
we will [ __ ] do bonus episodes we do
live streams with you guys
check it out a lot of good stuff on
there thanks a lot thank you kippy and
have a nice shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the pride of the
chicago
comedy scene the [ __ ] magic man
t-bone toby mcmullen yeah t-bone hey
what up how about the bears
come out oh we had a great game on
sunday the saints came marching in we
stomped them out
or [ __ ] mad maggie we've been saying
he's a piece of [ __ ] all year we knew it
was coming
the loss ain't going to stop us next
year you should do two in case they lose
do two different versions
i just did yeah
so we checked out when toby talked
we're both like you should do that thing
you did oh sorry okay say deep dish keep
it moving
yeah let's go gang we could not be more
excited to have our incredibly special
guest
here with this one today we've been
trying to work this out for a while
yeah a lot of sit-downs out there on
dipmars boulevard
to make that happen yeah a lot of
sit-downs a lot of
consultations with doctors yeah
emergency room
visits a couple of co-pays we had to hit
yeah
i mean yeah if you're going to want to
go to my page it's called jana's head
covid
um kickstarter
for uh my uncovered medical bills and
then we
almost didn't make it here because me
and t-bone had a little miscommunication
on the text
yeah and i went to queens first and then
westchester
got out of the car and then he told me
he actually did send me the right one
after he changed the address so
i'm here thank god look at it we love it
gang that voice you hear is our
incredibly
incredibly special guest that we're so
happy to have with us today he has his
own comedy central half hour he has a
stand-up special out right now called
blowing the light
of course you know him from the wildly
successful
wildly funny history hyenas it is a
brand new podcast out called long days
gang do us a favor give it up for the
one yeah the only
giannis papas johnny thanks for coming
pal thank you that that was just such
the world we've been living in for the
past what you know
year you made me nervous that whole time
because i felt you looking at me yeah
i'm looking and i stuttered on a couple
of words
and then you just gave me nothing on the
aunt today
i laughed at that yeah i laughed at that
and toby picked it up on the old mic
there yeah but i'll tell you
i got you understand i know you're
disapproving of my team
you did that with soda what do you want
from me
oh [ __ ] that's part of the intro yeah
you look like you got the same
two-bit joke down every time you look
like a guy who might do the same bit
twice dude
he looks like the guy who likes a few
beers yeah
definition of a hat if you know what i
mean he wrote some good bits in 09 and
really phones it in
no but what he gave me like a real like
good comic intro sure yes sir and then
there was
silence yeah because that's the world
we've been living in we're just people
at home you just
are just eating watching and we're going
like yeah we're doing a show
got a hope you got your vr glasses on
this is a world of comedy now are you
garbage brought to you by oculus
pappas now pause for laughter pause for
laughter t-bone put that in post
laughter for yoni p you can hear the
cheez-its munching from here
but boy do we adapt like roaches stick
it move baby stick and we
are [ __ ] the roaches of the arts
yeah we're on rooftops uh
yeah we'll [ __ ] show up in your
basement for your mom
do the same jokes twice anywhere i'm
coming i don't care
[ __ ] corporate zoom shows the whole
nine yards
making fun of people's home office ah
dale yeah yeah pretty shitty bookshelf
there
all right that'll be a hundred dollars
please yeah
you know we're roaches dude you know
what you get a texturing boy like yo
you're going to show tonight yeah yeah
the one on the nine train
yeah yeah yeah time is your set i don't
know what time's the train get into 40
seconds
i know i just saw that that's pushing
they're pushing the show is doing it i
got sent avails from stand-up new york
hey what time can you be on the sixth
street yeah get the [ __ ] out of here i
wrote
i said lose my email address until you
become a comedy club again yeah yeah
yeah
i'm i'm too old to get an email like
that i it makes me feel bad
i respect it though and i i i i've been
saying
that well just like what you're saying
we adapt we're [ __ ] we're still doing
it
i think the kids that are out there now
doing the open mics who didn't [ __ ]
crumble and move home
that are doing it in the streets [ __ ]
in washington square park on the train
that's going to be a special class no
they will be better waiters when this is
all set now absolutely
be some top-notch
they'll be dropping that chair they will
have a great unsuccessful podcast
i mean you know you guys you guys got it
you got a good one
you've got to keeping the foot on the
gas the the buzz is there and like yeah
so most people it's like you want to do
a podcast in a book club and it goes for
like
i had six failed podcasts before i got
one this is our third third
this is our third that finally hit shout
out to schultzy by the way
yeah he gave you guys a little shout out
yeah we did it we did that he did our
show yeah he's been [ __ ] great yeah
nice little bump yeah i know he helped
me he produced my specialty yeah
this is great by the way yeah thank you
you're a comedy club fantastic i love
that place
shout out emilio 100 he's a [ __ ] guy
who makes it happen no matter making it
[ __ ] happen
all summer doing a million different
things busting his [ __ ] ass yeah you
gotta love him
yeah he sees a strip club he's like
let's do it and i've been to that trip
club and every time i go i ain't [ __ ]
going back
and then like four months later i'm like
what a cash ain't that
i've done it three times and i've done
the same thing like never do it again
and he calls him like i got nothing else
going on we love going down to the
clearage [ __ ] couple of rooms get up
saturday walk around the boards a little
bit down there in ac
yeah a little diner breath in the summer
you know it's [ __ ]
great i don't mind in the summer it's
like yeah ac is kind of like
um it's like america's it's like a
america's path like you're walking into
oh it's like the way pittsburgh used to
feel before it got gentrified
if you go in with that with that
mentality you're gonna have fun
well if you're just like yeah this is
[ __ ] this place is a [ __ ] hell
hole and just embrace it it's fine but
some people go down they're like yeah
we're gonna
be like you know [ __ ] shooting dice
and stuff it's like dude it ain't that
anymore
taking mushrooms and going down and
going down to ac specifically to walk
around the casinos walk around the
boards and just get all tripped out
that's i mean if you look at it i mean
that's [ __ ] that's having a positive
attitude yeah
i can't go bad quick though dude that's
like being in a haunted house on trooms
some
last time we were down there i went into
a cvs i was like buying batteries or
something and the guy behind me
actively bleeding from his face in line
and i wasn't wasn't buying band-aids
i'm like oh [ __ ] dude you're like
thinking and he was buying a magazine or
something like what the [ __ ] dude like
you need
attention i've got a little [ __ ]
neosporium and some gauze there fella
atlantic city's like you're in the
casino you stay in the stay
in the casino i'll leave you leave to go
get one of those famous sandwiches dirt
at night
you do that at 11 a.m yeah yeah yeah
yeah do that with a new birthday yeah
get a hoagie in the morning and keep it
[ __ ] moving i love the tropicana too
because that's where he ha
where is he he does it at the tropical
count emilio right uh it was yeah at the
trout
although then he just moved to the
clarion hotel yeah but the one that it
used to be at the truck
was like the stripper stage yeah that
thing because those are [ __ ] hell
what was the name it was bomb bomb
bomb every time i was there and the
staff's just like wanting the show to
wrap up as soon as it's done they
[ __ ] move the stage put the strippers
on the poles
yeah yeah good times yeah that's the
time i love it well giannis thank you so
much for being here today we couldn't uh
we're very happy to have you
uh we i know bits and pieces like our
new york kid new york city city kid all
the way
like like philly kids we like let you
know we're we're like the jews of what
cities we're from
yeah we slip it in in every sentence
while i'm a jew we go like i'm from
philly so you know what i [ __ ] myself
all the time
we're from new york so like you don't
even we're always like you don't know
what this city used to look like
we're always telling you you're going
like look i don't give a [ __ ] i'm here
to be an actor yeah yeah yeah i don't
care what [ __ ]
what it was like before gentrification i
know you got slices and all that stuff
your real deal cool new york city kid
80s i was yeah i i grew up in 80s and
90s here so i
it was a different city crazy and now
it's back
yeah dude we were talking before we came
on it's getting [ __ ]
dicey it's like john travolta's career
it's just [ __ ]
bad fiction no chocolate croissants here
my friend
i'll tell you that no i didn't get a
commission like it
yeah i did a sketch here actually around
the block right here yeah cause this is
where it's like
back again to what it was this is
[ __ ] places are boarded up
shops are empty and the [ __ ] the
heroin addicts are the brains
the bridge over here connecting the two
avenues is ridiculous the tents just
oh yeah yeah yeah isn't it crazy how
quick it can happen like that oh yeah it
just lets you know how tenuous and
precarious
good times or civilization it just oh
two seconds like the joker said you just
give it a little push i talked to
someone who had like
psychosis and they were like the scary
thing is everybody's walking around they
have no idea how
close they are to completely losing it
at any second oh cool and that
rattled me to the core that was like a
decade ago i think about it every
[ __ ] day
oh look it's today today i'm going just
like one one parking ticket i'm gonna
[ __ ] lose
it no yeah saturday is pretty precarious
especially if you live in new york
yeah yeah new york is like a place that
we all have stockholm syndrome here
dude you know it's so bad it just tries
it's the city tries to [ __ ] it to the
point
we're so [ __ ] up that when we catch a
train quick i'm like i love this place
yeah just because i got on the train and
like right away look at that real new
york moment right there
yeah yeah yeah yeah it makes you feel
good yeah it's complete stockholm
syndrome then when you go and you live
somewhere else you're just like
that's when you realize like oh my god i
was in abusive relationships that's a
bad dude
but you want to come back he was hitting
me you want to come back though
i love it it's like a cold it's like a
line of coke yeah
it's like a line of coke every day love
it west side upper east side on a
saturday [ __ ]
whoa you know what but the crimes aren't
getting like that like they're getting
like
insane we got to get that vaccine uh
well like dude i mean the slashings are
up on the [ __ ] dude people are
getting pushed on the floor
he was just walking around and he was
like chopping people dude google new
york slashings there's like four a day i
love it yeah
they love it a guy got killed at the
dollar slice spot yeah right on the
corner
two people two people died within two
blocks from here and i was back the next
day you can't pass up that deal
two brothers ain't too shabby check out
two brothers all over ketchup
and uh american cheese but you know what
made by two indian guys but what can you
yeah yeah yeah
i don't do pizza made by indians nothing
what's your best really you know i go
mexican or italian and that's
smart what's your best life i see a
greek i go to boston i see a greek back
there i'm not doing it
yeah yeah best slice just plain slice
yeah but where though where are you
going to get a slice
okay best slice slice spot i'm gonna go
pizza supremo
which is uh you wouldn't never think it
where is that it's
in it's it's across from the garden it's
across from the garden oh
wait what yeah and so you wouldn't think
it but the slices buy the slice fresh
out of the
it's on eighth it's on um night it's on
the ninth
it is wait it's on night yeah yeah
you're saying that it's on ninth block
anywhere in the city it's like where you
know the post office is across from
um yeah yeah it's right below that right
right below that like two like half a
quarter of the blockheads i've been
there that's a good [ __ ]
good slot brooklyn no that's the thing
you wouldn't be moany pizza gardeners
right
well spamoni is good for uh the spamoni
gardens
the the sicilians are great but they
used to be better before the owner got
murdered in his backyard two years ago
yeah oh yeah i remember that
yeah holy [ __ ] yeah and then the other
place lucali which is great which is in
carroll gardens
uh that rolls it with the wine bottle
that guy yeah yeah
so he got stabbed on court street like
19 times really
yeah it's hilarious like during the day
that's it not enough ice in the coke
[Laughter]
charge them for a refill that's like a
pie spot yeah and that became like one
of the best spots which is funny because
carol gardens when i was growing up was
like
mafia and italian and you can even tell
there's like a couple of uh
social clubs still there on the third
avenue and so he's a kid from brooklyn
who grew up going to de fars which is
like the old school greatest pizza in
the world
right and so he modeled his place in the
forest and now the neighborhood's like
the most expensive
neighborhood in brooklyn right it's nice
and so now he got stabbed
at like 11 a.m on a sunday where like
stroller moms were like pushing their
babies from you know going down the
steps of their four million dollar
brownstones
and there's some [ __ ] attacks
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] owe me money you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] holy [ __ ] oh my
god
oh my god oh my god baker
come outside yeah tyler get out here
jesus christ the brooklyn our mom said
we're moving to is happening
because you know that's crazy like your
parents are always nervous when you move
to new york just be careful don't look
at black people in the face or whatever
that's [ __ ] nuts dude damn give us
the full story
yeah start from the beginning i want to
know yeah yeah i want to hear it
bro you're a brooklyn kid i grew up in
park slope so
which has always been nice like if you
go from parks a little bit of cash
yeah if you asked my podcast partner
chris
chris yeah he would just he would just
call me the f word he would just say he
grew up
it was like a so we cuz you're a smart
kid right
yeah and italian or all greek greek 100
percent great 100 percent great so i
could just out of curiosity why wasn't
it uh
how big is the greek community in parks
not big so why wasn't it a story uh or
you know something like that that's a
good question because my parents so
my dad grew up in brooklyn uh-huh his
dad owned a diner of course yeah
yeah yeah that's just what we did we got
to be one of them yeah do you remember
the diner did you used to no i was too
yeah because my dad my parents had me
when uh they were my dad was 48 my mom
was 43 which back then was like what do
you you know what are you guys doing
yeah yeah now everyone's doing that i'm
gonna have a kid when i'm like 60. yeah
yeah
i heard a kid who was 39 the other day
said i'm still young i'm like dude no
you're not
no you're not i'm still young though
yeah yeah hi bro
yeah i just had a kid and i'm in my 40s
so that's what we do now
congratulations by the way that's why
the chinese are going to win because
we're just
not going to have the manpower yeah no
not at all when they hit the [ __ ]
border we're just going to like we have
no people
yeah a bunch of old dads pushing babies
well i'm the same way i mean i'm 34
you're in you're you're 40. i'll be four
i'll be 45.
you're still planning on the same pitch
yeah yeah yeah yeah no it's good
it's when it starts this is when it
starts i believe when life starts
yeah i hope it starts at 45. starts at
45. i love it
all right so all greek yeah your
grandfather had a diner your parents had
you late brothers and sisters
two brothers now one were they born are
they they're much older one's 10 years
older and the other one is 16 and a half
years old
yeah yeah i got that in my face same
same i got a six somebody's 16 years and
10 years younger than that wow
yeah yeah divorce though but yeah yeah
no [ __ ] but yani was a happy accident
i was like uh you know a couple of misca
i'm here
because thank you for the pour a little
beer out for a couple of my
siblings who died before they could make
it yeah i wouldn't be here but yeah
i might have been i don't know what was
going on i think maybe they were trying
to save their
marriage because they also had a law
practice together they were lawyers
okay so they worked together my mom was
a human rights lawyer but then she
also worked with my dad at his he had a
law
he did like uh he started with uh
personal injury then he did meta
then he did uh immigration and then he
did medical malpractice were they both
born here are they both good my mom was
born in crete
when uh she was there when the nazis
occupied she was born she was there she
was like a little girl she remembered
the island of crete and greece and my
dad was born in brooklyn his parents had
a diner
in um so i think park slope was like a
little closer to the city
they became like lawyers park slope was
park slope was like uh
it was a bad it was like an all irish
neighborhood that's why it's the only
other neighborhood
bay ridge park slope and the irish
parade here
there's they do the saint patty's they
parade in park slopes still oh dude they
used to be all irish like my block when
i grew up there's tons of like
retired irish cops and tons of items
what my whole family is yeah
yeah it's for philly yeah we're all
[ __ ] yeah yeah everyone's a [ __ ]
meathead
everyone's like a pipe fitter or a
[ __ ] cop that's all yeah that's all
it is
yeah and so and then like they were
my parents were older so when they
bought it they bought it in the 50s they
bought it for like 28 thousand dollars
they brought it from an irish family who
didn't even have like a gas stove or
they were still doing like wood in the
basement is this a brown stone
it's a brick townhouse attached okay
yeah they're all attached
that's what you grew up in i grew up in
that yeah wow and my grandparents lived
upstairs
now that's like a tenant like you know
really so my grandma my greek
grandparents funny story this is this is
funny and i wasn't alive yet but
this is a greek thing okay greeks have
vendettas
you
italian pizzeria owners too
[Laughter]
yeah yeah but they'll like kill you in
the street like greeks will just like
hate you secretly and hate family yeah
like really backwards third world [ __ ]
so
um my grandfather and his brother
were the business partners they started
as like bus boys they saved up together
they got a restaurant okay
and so the american dream baby my my
grand uncle
lived with my grandfather and
grandmother upstairs all three of them
which is weird yeah that's kind of
that's going to be attention and like
maybe my uncle was gay and you couldn't
be gay back then like he had an irish
girlfriend somewhere or something but
like he didn't make kids which back then
just meant you were gay yes
you didn't have any family and kids you
were definitely like you were a little
suspect yeah a little light in the
loafers hold on i want to comment how
chasey that was he didn't make kids
yeah that's that's how you knew it was
guys you know no kids like back then
tim dillon would just have a wife yeah
and then you would never know he's gay
except for the fact that he [ __ ] guys
if you caught him [ __ ] a guy
that's the only way you would know if
you were in the bedroom that's the only
way you would know you were the guy he
[ __ ] yeah the only way
you use it other than that you're
sweeping under the [ __ ] rug yeah yeah
so my grandfather uh died first
so that's awkward so now my grandmother
just lives upstairs
with my grandfather's brother and they
didn't talk
for eight years they lived in the same
house
jesus and they didn't speak ever again
until
um she died first and then he died they
never spoke that's insane and they lived
in the same house
eight years after my grandfather died
how old were they at this time like
eight seventies
like in their seventies yeah and i asked
my dad like what was the fight over he
goes i don't know they probably don't
even know anything nobody knows
nobody knows nobody [ __ ] knows nobody
knows yeah he had to cover a dinner
shift or something and yeah
[ __ ] something happened and then he
stopped [ __ ] talking to each other
yeah
i mean imagine living in the house eight
i mean that's you got to respect
i love that they didn't even talk
passing each other like you know there
was one bathroom on the second floor i
don't know how they did that
they're just in separate rooms and they
kind of just i i i have that in me
though we've talked i've talked about it
i don't talk to my dad i saw my dad this
is how philly trash i am i don't talk to
my five and talk to my father in like
seven years or something like that
um i saw him in a last time i was home i
saw him in a wah-wah parking lot and we
walked right by each other
it's the most billy dirtbag thing in the
world wow wow yeah the wawa parking lot
i had my [ __ ] hot dogs and gatorade
kept it moving yeah and you're an irish
kid so you never go to therapy you'll
just drink it down push it down
irish kids johnny knows yeah buddy i had
a six or last night to take the edge
don't feel that no why would i want to
think about that [ __ ] keep it going i'm
pushing right now
[Laughter]
something gang real quick want to talk
to you about our amazing sponsor
sheath underwear dot com
absolutely fantastic product developed
by an iraqi war veteran
to keep your dick and your balls
separate
yeah guys for cooling purposes there's a
two pouch system it sounds crazy it's
fantastic
your balls going one pouch your wiener
goes in with another pouch don't touch
these vacations
they don't touch each other your balls
don't touch your leg which
but i didn't know i needed until i got
oh brutal they sent us like 25 pairs of
these i wear them
every single day yeah they're my main
underwear i know you hear that a lot on
podcasts
but also too you hear sheath underwear a
lot on podcasts cause this guy [ __ ]
supports a lot of comedy podcasts he
does yeah he he he he's very supportive
of our show he's very supportive of a
lot of shows of the shows you guys watch
support them sheath underwear dot com
you use promo code garbage you save
twenty percent baby
i ain't talking five percent i ain't
talking ten percent not fifteen percent
twenty percent use promo code garbage
sheath underwear dot com
support the people who support the show
now back
to the show why the [ __ ] does wawa is
like
you want to order a sandwich you know
and then the lady's standing right there
why do i gotta like be a computer expert
the whole
the whole computer philadelphia we
apologize
about the computer situation at wawa it
was for some reason it was better when
you order over the counter
yeah they're trying to catch up to
sheets they're trying to
they're trying to be something they're
not every everyone's that's the way
everyone's doing it yeah just probably
inventory kids
dirtbags yeah you're probably scared
just let me get a tiger you're probably
stealing ham they probably have to do it
to [ __ ] keep track of that
yeah hoagie or coffee yeah because then
you go like back but you know if you
[ __ ] up on the mail you gotta go back
back back back
you see everybody's dirty [ __ ]
fingerprints on it you know what i mean
there's like spackle and [ __ ] from the
[ __ ] lunch crew came in
yeah everybody in philadelphia you got
covered got it off a wall watching yeah
i would have been yes probably yeah so
that's it yeah we grew up in uh brooklyn
some i think that was like a class
like park slope was like that one the
neighborhood that was like
working class and then people from
brooklyn who i think got like
jobs in the city they moved there
because the brownstones were nice
because at first the lower part of park
slope used to be nicer in the upper part
was like more working classically and
then it flipped like people wanted to
live
closer to the park that constantly
happens excuse me neighborhoods in new
york yeah
like soho used to be like empty that was
like where the mob went to like
kill you in like a yeah warehouse yeah
and then like wherever lesbians and gay
guys go that's yeah that's turns out i
have a [ __ ] house because they got a
lot of cash
no kids well they're the marines of
gentrification they go in first
start a softball game and then like they
[ __ ] get mugged a bunch they're tough
those lesbians
lesbians are the first ones in yeah like
park slope down on fifth avenue which
was bad when i was a kid
so it was like 7th avenue prospect park
west which was where i lived was pretty
good was good
and then uh sixth avenue was the line of
demarcation
and then fifth aviation it was like yeah
fifth avenue you got like it got really
dicey but then lesbians started moving
in fifth avenue and then next year block
by block
mid 90s it started and it started all
over new york that's when it started in
the mid 90s
gentrification but before that night a
lot giuliani julian it was a lot a lot
of it was giuliani
a lot of it was the economy the tech
bubble coming in yeah yeah
good stuff a lot of it was just suburbs
being so horrible
mm-hmm that like kids didn't want to
work at panera bread and they just
they're lifeless dude i go back now my
parents live in this i go back now and
i'm like
oh what the [ __ ] you gotta get in the
car to [ __ ] go everywhere like you
i'm like i wanna get a cup of coffee i
gotta get in the car drive seven minutes
to wawa park go ahead and ignore my dad
get back in and leave you know what i
mean
i love the burbs i don't know what
you're talking about yeah well the burbs
are passing you just moved you're around
which we want to we want to get into
yeah i moved to the concert wait i got
more
so in the brown so in in the townhouse
if
you we didn't have a goat in the
backyard that we [ __ ] or anything like
that i know where you're going i'm a
greek kid at some point
there's a lamb in the back it's brains
[ __ ] a little boy yeah i mean boys in
the yard did you make your own olive oil
no no because they do that i mean you go
to greek guy's house i mean there will
be like a [ __ ] they will figure out a
way to make a vineyard they'll figure
out
what they're doing like at the a.a.a
they will do it they have like a one
foot by one foot they'll have it hanging
yeah
yeah yeah they'll figure it out to make
it recreate grease somehow but you were
you were basically not an only child but
so if when you started to be able to
remember things your your brothers were
out on their own they were 14 15. yes
they were gone
so by the time you got 14 15 was there
cousins it was their cousins in their
neighborhood no i was just
they were all older so you and your crew
it was me and my friends
yeah we i grew up with my friends
basically were they all greek kids irish
kids they were all mixed
it was mixed it was irish jewish uh
italian
um i grew up uh it's like a movie
it was like sleepers it was like now
yeah black kid spanish kid
park slope is actually probably one of
the most diverse neighborhoods
naturally um colin quinn grew up there
i'm first he'd go
two blocks for me so that neighbor was
just for some reason it was just so
diverse
and it had like hispanics blacks whites
irish a lot of irish that it was
originally like you know in the early
turn of the century
it was irish and then before that it was
rich
before it went working class irish was
rich like a lot of those homes that's
why there was there were probably nicer
homes yeah
but a lot of brooklyn was because
brooklyn was like the vacation homes
for people who lived in the cities you
have to take a boat to go there you know
jesus
yeah 1800s those those houses were built
in the 1800s those were people's like
wealthy people's country homes yeah and
then like you know they moved out
farther and it's how it goes yeah it
must have been awesome back then
probably was awesome yeah living yeah
the east river
and imagine like if you were a killer
and want to kill people you could kill
people and get away with it
you could do anything yeah that was wide
open like there's no dna none of that
[ __ ] like
cameras yes dude i was talking to my
roommate i couldn't have killed him
and gotten the bot like you would get
caught you just can't there's cameras in
our lobby there's cameras in the hallway
cameras on the elevator cameras at the
gas station you're [ __ ] and even if
you're on camera they just [ __ ]
any hair you left there you're [ __ ]
they'll find you back then it's like you
had to see that you had to
see the guy killing yeah like they asked
witnesses and they're like
what's going on there yeah like no of
course we didn't see he's gonna kill me
nobody kills people out in the open you
know what i mean it's like a bronx
yeah he's [ __ ] he's dead in his room
you know a bobby would have to walk by
with his [ __ ] nice
all right you too all right all right so
that's the picture
yeah i like it good scoot good student i
was a horrible student so i went to
public school
till about uh fourth grade okay
failure in public school then i went to
private brooklyn i went to quaker school
brooklyn friends really yeah friends
they were all these weird kids where we
grew up yeah it's very suburban
yes so brooklyn friends i cannot imagine
you in like a quaker circle where
they're like everyone's going to be
quiet and
he's like yeah yeah yeah
just doing marisa yeah i'm not going to
be quiet
until you come over and suck this dick
and then i'll suck that dick
that's right i love them quakers they
[ __ ] quiet
um i loved it though quaker school was
cool that my brother went to one yeah
silent meeting is cool classes hour of
worship or what are they called
one time a week you gather and uh you
sit in silence
yeah and if you're a kid and someone
farts it's the
funniest thing you can't stop laughing
so yeah and then every morning there's
like silence
quaker weddings are really beautiful
though so funerals are cool too do you
ever go to one they just sit in silence
they sit in silence and you're allowed
to stand up at any time like there's no
order yeah and just say something
whatever moves whatever you're moved to
say yeah you just like hey i'm sorry
for the family or like you can share a
story or remember it's like
it was the coolest thing i had a wedding
you're sorry for the family
with this [ __ ] slots over here
yeah and uh yes wedding's the same thing
nobody talks unless they move to speak
and then
the bride and groom just stare at each
other yeah which is kind of a little
weird but yeah but i mean it's cool
because like if you're marrying the
wrong person in that moment
right there i'm sorry that's it
i went through the whole thing while i
was looking at it i couldn't do 30
seconds of eye contact i'm walking out
take back the sterno trains it's over
nah they don't get credit man and you
know they were always against slavery
like quakers are cool
yeah yeah and so then from there i got
left back in ninth grade
because quit bragging at the quaker
school what the [ __ ] kid couldn't even
be quiet for an hour
hey yada you're gonna have to come back
and sit again for an hour i've never
seen this before in my life that's how
[ __ ] bad a student i was i got left
back at a [ __ ] quaker squad
[ __ ] they let everybody yeah you don't
even get grades you get pass
or like fail ass minus or get a
different piece of wood
go to like [ __ ] live in the woods but
obviously you don't have to be
the of the quaker religion your family
is greek worth it no yeah
no it's just quicker schools nowadays
anyway anybody can go yeah like my dad
my brother
yeah penn charters at quaker school yeah
yeah you know back then like if you went
to school like that it was like
eight to 12 grand it cost your parents
you know now those things are like
it's like 40 grand yeah yeah my
brother's got two kids in private school
it's [ __ ] nuts
it's crazy nuts yeah so uh no yeah i did
ninth grade twice
and then uh well how's it see that's so
funny dude it was always my fantasy yeah
okay to get my senior year of high
school
i was even though i loved my friends i
wanted to get left back so i could play
football one more time
and be a little bit older and double the
lunches yeah
they ain't a [ __ ] texas tommy i'll
tell you this
coming mayor you telling me if you pass
this course
i leave that cafeteria
ah [ __ ] mary makes those good sloppy
jokes
keep the milks coming baby
no but i always wanted to but the weird
thing is i've never
the guy who got left behind that was it
with the friends right
it was it was weird because i was young
i'm born at end of august i was always a
little young
for uh for that grade one i was like
and i was just so i didn't go to class
my first year i just would cut
class i wouldn't go i got t-minuses i
was just i was the class clown
i got suspended all the time i was
making people laugh i couldn't control
myself in class so
they just my my average was like point
67 was like a d-minus
i was a d-minus average in my ninth
grade so they were just like
uh in order for you to get into a decent
college one day just re-do it it's
almost like you failed that year
yeah so it's like got a mulligan yeah so
i just redid it damn which was weird
so uh yeah so i i for a while i'd lied
to i
took one year back so like when people
used to ask me how old i was i would say
i was one year younger
really in my mind i'm like the [ __ ]
system took one year
away from me i'm taking one that's that
greek vengeance [ __ ] right there
the system takes one for me i take one
from them and then i just felt like a
[ __ ] woman doing that
i'm not 42 i'm 41. 13 with 13 with a
full beard now i'm 11.
so who takes one year back full chest
hair
[Laughter]
i'll be 10 in june um
and then you turned it around no never
turned it
became a uh no but i did go to college i
passed went to american university in
d.c
see that's a good school how did you get
in there good school well uh
i'll tell you how i got in there this is
uh american university if you research
it
i got in like the year after
the um the uh the the president of the
school
whose name is uh richard berenson at the
time right
he was caught making like obscene phone
calls
to students like really obscene like the
jerky boys no
like sexual [ __ ] yeah all right like
okay and he was doing it for a while so
it's the wrong city to do that it's like
the [ __ ] government's
yeah yeah so they tapped the phone with
fans yeah this is a great you can google
this story it's a massive story
so he got they caught him he wrote a
book that he got raped by his mother
when he was a kid or whatever he but he
had tenure so
he stayed he's a really popular
professor i took his class he was a
famous scientist he's an astronomer
but uh it really tarnished the
university's reputation so you snuck in
and i got in it's a
c minus students
yeah yeah so it was like right now yeah
i'll come to your school they let in
like a bunch of kids that you were like
and the school was just like and then it
slowly climbed back up in reputation
there you go they opened the law school
like they didn't have a law school and
then it grew but
so now when people say you went to a you
i'm like yeah but at the time
that's what happened the quaker school
jv squad
yeah it like dipped in reputation i just
slipped in that's [ __ ] awesome yeah
yeah because that was a c minor student
and that's a good that's not that's
great because my cousin went there yeah
fantastic school yeah
all right we gotta get into some
questions gonna get into some questions
all right so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna ask you a series of
questions to determine whether you're
garbage or not some from
growing up some from now because you
know we're suburban kids we're excited
that you're out in the burbs
yeah uh treating yourself [ __ ] doing
it right out there yeah
also the double ninth grade you're
starting off kind of in a hole for the
tesla well i want to say greek kind of
starts it on a hall right
not they're hard working you know what i
mean [ __ ] guys working [ __ ]
not for me and i'll tell you why because
i i live in astoria i've been out there
for a long time
i look at those guys those greek guys
like you know the second third
generation kids
as all cool as [ __ ] yeah like to me i
don't think you're garbage i think
you're super cool you always got cool
jeans on nice jacket [ __ ] like
very well put together dress well thank
you yeah you're like an italian in that
sense
yes they care they they care so much
about you
so i see sharpness now i understand you
know the connotation you know
immigrant background all that kind of
stuff we've all been there let's let's
not cut the cheese
um do you think you're garbage
i know i'm garbage okay yeah i mean i
know okay i mean
my ass is half clean right now i mean
i'm not
you can wear this [ __ ] out of a yankees
hat i'll tell you this [ __ ] every
yankees had a grey sweatshirt
kid's looking nice i mean my my oldest
brother went to oxford
georgetown law oh so in comparison
you've always been the shittier one
have been in the garbage i just became
you know i started doing skits
yeah yeah yeah yeah we're all comedians
yeah yeah but still both people i got
kicked out of school
you know you come from good stock
parents i come from nice people
like hard-working nice people
grandparents immigrated here my mother
was born
she came here she went to law school she
was ruth bader ginsburg's generation she
was one
she went to school with she was friends
with david dinkins the former mayor of
new york shout out to dinks yeah they uh
he
hit on her he put his hand on her after
he had kids in the family he's dead now
so i'll just be honest i mean i want to
[ __ ] my mom i tried to [ __ ] my mom
really yeah yeah you heard it here first
when they were in uh uh law school
together uh so hard working came up
you know my dad came up working in his
father's diner and then he went to korea
with one another also you could put a
wig
on i could put a wig on i mean yeah i
mean that's
my job i love it my job is to like do
cameo and i'm like what's up this is
marisa
happy birthday stephen in westchester
that's
it your dad was in korea my dad fought
in korea god damn yeah and then he came
back with the law school so they kind of
moved to park slope which was they lived
in flatbush and then yeah
they were killing that's the american
dream they came here comes here
their brother went to law school and
then i came and i was like getting
kicked out of school
and smoking weed and you know you reap
the benefits of it baby come on
that's what it's all about my
grandfather's you know they say hey we
work so hard so you don't have to i'm
like thank you
thank you did you mean it when you said
it
cause i took you seriously yeah you
wanted a better life i [ __ ] got one
i'm not at the diner 14 hours a day
because we're on our way to rockaway
with a couple of nutcrackers in the car
you're gonna [ __ ] have a job because
you work so hard for nothing if i do
that
you're prepared exactly i love that
[ __ ] logic actually
absolutely is the townhouse still in the
family the townhouse is still in the
family
um yeah it's worth a lot more than it
was then way more than 28k
but it's in a trust so we can't uh
because my mother has alzheimer's she's
in a
uh so it's secure it's secure so and
that pays for her
right so it's a whole legal loophole
where you just you know you don't pay
taxes yeah it's good that's what your
account helps you with that's what
accountants for
help you tax evasion yeah that's all it
is
that's all it is yeah yeah none of the
honest pop it's comments are any way
associated but are you garbage
kevin ryan incorporated our holy
enterprises i love it when i hear like
people say you know uh
podcasters comedians seem like their
right wing it's like
yeah we own our own [ __ ] business
yeah we're all small you own your
business you had to pay those [ __ ]
taxes you'd probably lean right too
yeah it's easy to be left-wing when
you're collecting benefits from the
government
i'm that's what i'm left with too laura
ingram starts making a lot of sense yeah
exactly not too shabby to look at either
you see that [ __ ] new york city ubt
text you're like can we move our studio
to texas somehow i know
well i'm i'm so stupid with all that
stuff he was telling me one of the main
reasons tom brady might have moved to
florida
yeah is [ __ ] no income tax same with
rogue yeah
most people on the left are stupid about
that that's why they're on the left well
i'm on the left yeah so it's like eileen
why don't you start making money you're
going like i kind of understand what
they're talking about well dude my
parents are going over their will and
i'm like ah
[ __ ] you know trump 2020. you see in
the test start looking at numbers i'm
like
[ __ ] yeah jesus christ all right we
gotta get into this that's too funny yes
we do we got the hot one babe we got a
hot app
we love it
you want to start it off yeah all right
now that you're a big one here now
you're out in the burbs right yeah
what supermarket do you or your wife
shop at shoprite
really that's nice what did when you
were in new york what were you shopping
at
uh i i never i ate out every night
diarrhea diarrhea that's why i'm
surprised i got covered bad it's like
because i didn't get sick after that
because like we
we're used to just like digesting rat
pisses on everything so
how long how long have you been out in
the burbs we live in more of a country
setting i'll be honest with you really
yeah
i'm even further than this version of
this is the country yeah
yeah but you guess in the city you think
that's the country it's true
you see a [ __ ] dog they got horses
money got cattle out here yeah oh my god
what the [ __ ] is that thing
what the [ __ ] is that it's your dog
johnny get a cab we're going back to
queens
[ __ ] out of here with this so i guess
it's kind of burpee yeah
so yeah it's a little barbie yeah but
you don't get it i live like
in the woods yeah it's like guys there's
[ __ ]
trees out there i have my own mailbox
suburban connected to my house yeah i've
never had any of that
all the time yeah this is what's awesome
someone's like you got to get a new roof
i'm like wow
yeah yeah 30-year roof you gotta get a
30-year-old like what are you talking
about get the landlord on the phone that
piece of [ __ ]
who did your driveway i'm like what yeah
the city
i thought the city thinking's on the
phone
i got a [ __ ] tip the garbage guy i'm
like he says hello to me i'm like
why do i gotta know this guy yeah yeah
that's dude that's suburban living baby
weird at first suburban living people
could tell out there if you come from
like new york or because you yeah you're
out front
lifting weights and a wife grilling in
the front yard like a dirt ball
hey maureen no because you're like
people
want to talk to you you're just
skeptical oh yeah [ __ ] you they're like
i live across the street like i got your
hand on your wall sure you do
let me see your [ __ ] passport i saw
you looking at my house
i bought a gun i got a gun i got a
[ __ ] gun did you yeah look at you
liberal kid grew up in new york i got a
gun now it's different when you're
all those wild bears people say like oh
guns it's like yeah i believe in gun
control and [ __ ] but like
it's easy to say you're against guns
when you're in new york you know you
call the cops somebody breaks in the
cops they're quick i mean everything's
on top
you're on the country yeah in the
[ __ ] country yeah you know the roads
ain't plowing yeah you're like they got
they got a [ __ ] they gotta get in a
canoe to get to your house yeah
you got to wake the horses up you know
what i mean yeah [ __ ] everyone had a
gun in new york
argument in the train would end like a
quentin tarantino movie
[Laughter]
it's actually one of the questions i've
definitely have you ever slept with some
sort of weapon by your bed but i guess
you answered that
voluntarily yes brooklyn when i was
growing up was bad new york was bad so
we i grew up with a lot of fear
yeah and anxiety it was just bad
everywhere so it was like
you got mug growing up i must have got
my hat stolen like a hundred times
it's like you couldn't keep a hat you
would just
it's a true thing what would they do
it's not an exaggeration you you would
turn a corner quite literally
and back then there was just roaming
packs there was a lot of kids running
around
[ __ ] you turn a corner you see 20
kids on halloween they would kids would
roll like 100 deep and they'd ch
i've been chased got jackets stolen it
was like been beat up it just happened
damn i remember me and my friend one day
walked down the train station
i meet my friend uh zack zarbo who's an
nba ref now italian kid
he's an nba ref true that's the new york
thing they still say somebody they say
their full name and then they're
ethnicity
yes you gotta give them the whole right
oscar pollock good kid yeah
you guys are [ __ ] pollock maybe a kid
was okay he's all right kids yeah we're
being a polite he's a good kid
you gotta give him the resume yeah so he
walked down good stream he's not a jump
shot like crazy you want to believe
actually he's a good good player we
walked down the stairs
it was just like we walked downstairs a
train and this is how it would happen
back then
and you just when you went down the
train you just
the kids were there and you just your
heart sinks there was no
chance it wasn't going to happen because
you can't turn it you turn around
100 you're done either way yeah i'm
scared of the showtime dancer
and here's the thing the funny thing
about new york that's hard to describe
people is like
there's no chance that it wasn't going
to happen
like it was going to how it was going
down was the issue
it was good they were going to do it you
were going to be the victim and it was
done
there was no like wow there was no
thinking like what had happened you're
like i can't believe that happened
when it didn't believe that yeah when it
didn't happen you were like holy [ __ ]
that didn't happen
yeah because that never you love this
city best city in the world you would at
least get smacked
or or they would say something like you
know you just hear someone call you if
it just happened you could bleep it
right t-bone trying to keep youtube
right you just called you'd get called
something but
most of the time you get kicked or you
would just get robbed so i remember that
time we walked down i remember we both
kind of like it's just a
you just and then we went and sat down
and just waited for it do you remember
where you were going
uh i i was i was wearing a walkman
um and we were going to the yellow one i
was suspended from school and we were
going to
my high school to uh pick up my
girlfriend and her friend and we were
going to go hang out cause he was he was
hooking up with a friend
nice yeah so then i just went to meet my
girlfriend in the winter with no jacket
[Laughter]
one time i walked home with no shoes
that happened too what oh yeah on
christmas and i had my christmas money
that i saved in my bus pass thing you
know your bus pass thing yeah
so like yeah they just took they came
from behind me was quiet
six kids took my timberlands off the
whole thing did you get the timberlands
for christmas
no i i don't remember where i got the
tim ones but i could definitely stay
i definitely watched you take them off
or did they take them off they took them
off
they asked me what size i was too and i
told them the truth
i was like i've been nine i always go
low i'm a kid six keep
[Laughter]
these are orthopedics they're
prescription they won't work for you i
got a small [ __ ] too leave me alone
i got athlete's foot i know i just told
the truth i was like i'm about a nine
yeah
and the most add the most standard size
for for young adults
kid was like i'm nine nine and a half so
much
i walked home in the icy snow in socks
it's cold
this is christmas day that was no before
christmas
so it was like sometime in december
before christmas yeah yeah so that was
my i had like 80 bucks in christmas
money
but it was my fault for carrying it like
having it on
because back then they actually in new
york they had something called mugger
money so you would walk around
town it's true too you'd have money in
case you got robbed so they wouldn't
hurt you you didn't have a 20.
yeah that's how wild it was my dad's car
got broken into during the day
while we were waiting to get into the
car that's a true story
he banged his hand on the hood and broke
his hand he was so mad because it got
broken into like nine times
people would have signs in the window
that said no radio and car and you used
to pull it out and take it with you i
mean how hilarious is this yeah i
remember that
radios you could pull out the face plate
on something i mean the car was [ __ ]
we were like getting our jackets on with
the door open in the middle of the day
they were so good at robbing radios and
[ __ ] some guy jimmied it
while we were getting ready and robbed
the car in like
minutes and we came out and they were
gone
and my dad was just like [ __ ] he
just [ __ ] broke his hand
oh there must have been a quiet ride huh
hey dad throw in a couple of never mind
yeah keep your [ __ ] mouth shut
but i want to ask my parents like you
know my father just passed away but i'm
like why didn't we move
you guys were lawyers how come we didn't
go to watch child staff yeah yeah
or at least long island you know what i
mean yeah no i'm kidding it's just what
you're saying in stockholm
city city city yeah they grow up in the
city they like the action i don't know
yeah i'm i mean i'm from the birds but i
get it like i could never
i mean i guess you know doing well house
out in the burbs yeah but
country other than that guys in the
country okay don't embarrass him with
the suburbs well no he nailed it before
his name
even if you leave for a little while
like i was away for two weeks and i
couldn't wait to get back
yeah yeah it's nice it's nice out there
you sleep a little better it's a little
quieter
you know sometimes a little too quiet
when i go home like to my family
yeah like this is too quiet yeah i need
something you're getting used to new
york
and you can't live in philly's not a
city you can live in right cities
philly's like block to block philly is
very block to block yeah you're like on
the block with the [ __ ] this is where
benjamin frank and then you turn the
block and you're in an episode of the
wire
yes philly's always been a city i say
you have to keep your [ __ ] head you
have to check your six you know what i
mean like
you can't just be one anybody can get
got at any time in philly
they could be for not saying thank you
for someone holding the door anything
yeah you can get guys
say thank you when you walk into a wawa
you know how many times i've seen
flights in huawei's parking lot yeah
people don't say thank you
yeah they just go you're welcome and
you're like oh here we go
and if you don't [ __ ] up and go oh [ __ ]
my bad i was [ __ ] thank you thank you
yeah and it's [ __ ] it's wrong i
remember i [ __ ] walked into a wawa's
uh and there was just some guy bleeding
on the steps
oh yeah it's just like it was three in
the morning
yeah that's what happens in a while i
was at three and a boarder good sandwich
yeah somebody didn't say
thank you all right so
first first venture out to the burbs of
the country yeah you got the house
yeah um driveways paved
i had to get repaved after i bought it
look at you yeah i did all cash though
seven grand
not bad yeah it's a long driveway you
got a guy now
garage lolly dropped the price seven
grand seven grand cash
if you tell the guy cash it always
cash's game i learned that at like six
yeah
everyone is trying to not pay taxes yeah
yeah that's why socialism will never
work for follies everyone wants the
benefits associated but nobody wants to
[ __ ] pay for somebody else find a
contractor that'll take
cash at a little bit of a less of a rate
a little less yeah problem is you got to
have cash which means you're probably
doing something illegal yeah
cause nobody has cash anymore no i i've
been hiding that cash for a long time
just like cash from gigs that i just
hide
yeah don't report that's awesome we hope
the clubs don't report it
oh yeah yeah that's i do it's always
it's always getting the w-2 or the you
know whatever the w-9s back they're like
oh they only reported 18 bucks this year
cool
i mean there's such scumbag let me just
i mean a lot of club owners are just the
filthiest pieces of [ __ ] you ever see in
your [ __ ] life send you a [ __ ] w-2
for like
500 you're like you couldn't have just
like just yeah
for crumbs and they're like [ __ ] all
right the government's got to know about
this 500 this one-nighter i did at your
[ __ ] bar
yeah you know you podcast like a rapper
you podcast like a rapper you're like
you're like i'm [ __ ] i'm not paying
my taxes i got two bodies on me yeah
yeah
yanny gets on the track and lets it all
out the driveway
got the driveway paved 7 grand cash 7
grand cash
pay me in [ __ ] cash yeah i like cash
i got a gun i'll protect it
[Laughter]
when you got a gun you got to go to the
range which is hard you got to learn how
to shoot
how to shoot it yeah at first you're
doing that i was worried that's good
yeah you got to learn
how to do it that's good how's your shot
not great but you know
i'll scare the [ __ ] out of a
[ __ ] i know how to do that i
don't know how to point it
i gotta close my eyes and [ __ ] hold
my dog but i'll get him
i'll [ __ ] get the guy i got you know
he's ten in the clip yeah a little
friendly fire on mittens
i mean collateral damage it happens a
little fracture side uh garage
garage yeah okay now big thing on the
burbs now
if you don't have this yeah okay you
want to enrich your family's life
yeah out there this is something that
you should do um
you have a garage do you have a
refrigerator in that garage
not yet no refrigerator yeah i gotta get
on getting one i plan on putting it
somewhere yeah in the basement or
something
yeah yeah it's gotta be filled with
beers yes scared
yes you put the [ __ ] ice cream put
the ice pops and [ __ ] in there for the
summer so they're gonna come into the
house
okay yeah all right that's it okay you
gotta do it get yourself a garage fridge
i see that that's a big thing in houses
because yeah yeah that's
yeah that's like dude in the suburbs
you're the [ __ ] you got two fridges
yeah good night
yeah the sellers in brooklyn you can't
have another fridge
we won't fit down the stairs don't make
the turn you wake up there's a [ __ ]
huge
water bug in there i see those
um all right i got one for you what's
the name this is a
a three-parter i guess the name of the
place you get your hair cut how much it
cost and what do you tip
i get my hair cut now for my
mother-in-law oh yeah mother-in-law cuts
my hair
in the house in the kitchen you can take
the kid at a park slope
but you can't take his hands off my
kitchen holy [ __ ] you got money huh
[Applause]
yes haircut takes four hours because you
got to start the gravy yeah you got to
get the meatballs going
you got to get the meatballs going you
got to get the game going get your bets
in
then she shows the [ __ ] up she's yapping
for [ __ ] 25 minutes
you got to give her a [ __ ] bailey's
pomoni
do you break her off a little green
that's she good boy i haven't really
tipped she does it for free before that
but
what is she a hair stylist she used to
be a hair stylist professionally yeah
she cuts a decent hair she's like a
[ __ ] secretary or something she cut
this yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then before that uh my boy
stefano and beyridge shout out panache
and he still cuts chris's hair okay what
a name for that [ __ ] barbecue because
i imagine that was always a pretty big
thing for a city kid go ahead
did you ever have did you ever have
lines in your head when you when i was a
kid i did look like sean king as a
teenager yes
i did the haircut glow the fade the
whole thing yeah
i wanted to be puerto rican i had a
dirty mustache here a lot of people in
the 90s want to be puerto rican you want
to be put
a couple of my irish cousins girls
wanted to be puerto rican it was
it was like hip-hop culture that was
when it hit yeah yeah so big fella
sweatshirt yeah
they would draw on their eyebrows and
[ __ ] yeah people used to put cuts in
their eyebrows and never did that but
that [ __ ] was awesome yeah mean you look
cool as [ __ ] when i when i was a little
kid it was like rap
started so like i was i remember i
remember when rap started i was like
five years old you know
we were wearing a forty percent man yeah
i used to put fat laces in and
everything oh
yeah we called them new yorkers that's
what we're calling these big fat laces
were called new yorkers oh wow
fluorescent colors and all that [ __ ]
yeah and it was just part of like you
i played basketball and baseball it was
like puerto rican kids black
that's just what hip hop it was like
the new thing it was like podcasts yeah
yeah
when you had the uh it was like a true
crime podcast
i think biggie did it yeah when you had
the regular barber in new york
did you ever have a photo with your
barber yeah
yeah yeah you always take a photo with
you yeah yeah yeah
you take a photo with the barber yeah
yeah of course
all right i got another one that's funny
so you're going uh you're out there in
the country going to a friend's house
you know let's say you're going to
virginia's house for dinner you and you
and the misses yeah you're going down
this have you been
versus my best friend yeah i mean we
hang out all the time yeah so that's
awesome yeah you got you got a built-in
best friend out there yes
you got your suburban best partner and
the wives families we hang out all the
time cookouts the kids
barbie can go see fireworks everything
man that's [ __ ]
awesome he's a good [ __ ] he i've said
this before he's the only guy i've been
on the road with that he takes you we go
to like classy wine bars after
shows we got like meat and cheese
yeah fourth of july barbecue legendary
top story on the invite paul
yeah i mean that's why i mean yeah why
am i turning around
what am i doing we got you investing i'm
having such a good time
at the table baby i forgot we're doing a
show here yeah
you order an espresso tell me let me get
uh
yeah charlie just bring us to check okay
no he is the best host him and his wife
stacy
the best it's always the spread he's
italian too so yeah they take pride
they take pride on it all that little
[ __ ] so this that that being said you're
going over versus for dinner yeah you
know it's going to be nice
you know you're bringing a bottle of
wine how much are you going to drop on
that bottle of wine
um a lot of good wines are like 15 to 20
bucks
so you know what you're doing are you
going blind i'm going coat the roan
uh any coat the rome will do
yeah uh and uh or not if we want if
we're going crazy
let's hear it which if we're going to
version i'm getting a bottle of jordan
that's going to be
that's a jordan cab it's a hundred yeah
a hundred dollar bottle of wine yeah so
we've done that too we don't and when we
used to drink scotch we would do
lagavulin 16. we don't [ __ ] around yeah
wow yeah it's worth you know like nice
things
i like nice things nice cigars you know
couple of sticks
we do a couple sticks yeah we do quality
i'm at the age where i like quality yeah
yeah yeah so i got to make
100 bucks on a buy that might be that
might be the biggest thing but when you
taste the biggest answer it's worth it
sure yeah jordan cat it's just jordan
cab's top shelf
good stuff it goes down like my one wine
can't have a bite
i want the wine to go down like yeah
like like a little bit
i'll no bite no bite i also don't know
anything about wine at all if you go
down smooth like i want my wine to sound
like you're tiptoeing down the stairs
with socks on
you know like nice and smooth and quiet
as trashy as i am i know a lot about
that [ __ ] but it's because i was
in domestic purposes because i was a
server at a
uh high-end restaurant for a while yeah
and also you guys are comics so there's
a little bit
we're all a little gay a little bit yeah
yeah a little bit
yeah yeah you guys probably had family
your friends were like iron workers or
whatever and then you're like come see
my
show oh yeah yeah yeah dude i guess i
come from the kind of family that will
make fun of me when i go to starbucks
yeah yeah
i just [ __ ] guy who went to starbucks
you guys were a duncan family
yeah star wars is definitely one step up
from dunkin dude i've gone to family
parties yeah and like they've been like
oh mr stallbox is here
[ __ ] new york liberal look at him hey
look who it is
[ __ ] guy yeah man yeah it's a bunch
of [ __ ] moocs yeah
i remember the first time i asked my i
think it was my my parents to come and
they're very supportive they're
absolutely fantastic and we were a
little artsy
but when i remember i invited them to my
first like uh guitar
music open mic my dad thought he was
like coming to see me in like a two-two
yeah yeah pulled your side after the end
like so are you guys
i mean tell me now it is okay it's all
right if you are
yeah uh what is the most you've ever
spent on a pair of jeans
uh not much i do levi's side
yeah everything's levi's or banana
republic discount at
86th street and bay ridge huh so i would
say 70 bucks maybe 80 bucks
i would have paid i would have i was
expecting 500 now the trick about jeans
is you don't got to go expensive with
jeans
you could even go uni glow they make
decent changes all about the
[Laughter]
nobody notices jeans their blue jeans
are black jeans keep it moving
same genes that when i go on the road
like doing weekends though i bring one
pair of jeans
seven pairs of snickers different
outfits i don't know what kind of day
i'm gonna have wear the same clothes
are you a sneaker head been since i was
a little kid i'm original i'm an
original sneaker head what's
up what's the longest you've had a pair
of shoes before putting them on wow
a long time yeah like years i mean i
have a few
i have a thousand dollar pair of tom
fords jesus that this is how much of a
sneaker i was
i had a show called a two-point lead on
aol aol has a lot of
they used to be they made a lot they
were owned by uh
uh they were time warner time warner
yeah they had a lot of money so it's
like we had a big budget and [ __ ] so we
were doing like the new fronts before
verizon bought them
so uh we got uh gronk to be in our
like they had money yeah yeah so they
were outfitting me and i was like all i
cared about sneakers
and they were like you got plenty of
stuff because i was like no i don't
really got anything but you
you under the you were able to keep
these i was able to keep these so this
is for that
this is how i do it but i'm keeping the
sneaks this is how i finagled it i'm
like i just you know i feel like when
i'm left i'm like when i have new
sneakers on
i just bring it confident i just bring
it you know it's just a thing
and they're going what are you talking
about garbage
how about these and they were like are
you [ __ ] crazy they're a thousand
dollar tom fords high top
black leather and then they so they said
okay finally i got them i negotiated
them they paid 500
so i got them half price and they were
they're
dope oh man that's something dirtbag
what was the first that's [ __ ] dude
that's so trashy i love it
and i'll tell you clean sneakers on your
friends right
so when i lived in miami she i i worked
in miami for a year
right and that's where i met her she
worked at um
uh because i got to i knew her comedy
what's like the
sax or some [ __ ] right so she barney's
barney's yeah
she used to get us geared towards yeah
really she's real sharp with all that
stuff yeah she knows good clothes good
fashion 20 off i was [ __ ] racking up
yeah
designer kicks yeah when i sell those
shits on poshmark they're going to be
worth a lot
what was your first break got you into
it as a kid would you buy a pair of
jordans
the first the first ones that i could
remember i was big on with the jordan
ones because we were kids yes
when that when that happened when jordan
started and jordan once hit it was the
jordan ones with the first ones i was
crazy about but even before that it was
like kangaroos like me and my friends
got into kangaroos really with this
zipper what does you put that [ __ ]
wild guy into your wife
no wildcats but definitely kangaroos
yeah air force
uh the um the old georgetown the weapons
it actually started with the weapons the
magic and bird weapons like your friend
would get the
the bird you'd get the magic that's
where it started was the weapons
and then the georgetown terminators high
top those were then those became hot the
whole the hoya
terminators i still have a pair of those
who was the
who am i thinking who is this if you're
a sneaker head you're [ __ ] trash
right
yeah yeah yeah put on a pair of shoes
you can [ __ ] adult
yeah i mean when i was a kid in the 90s
like a little kid the [ __ ] la lights
dropped that was a [ __ ] game-changer
when the la lights dropped
you wore the la light drops you're trash
oh yeah you're sure
trish you're [ __ ] trash they didn't
fit me
and i had what they were like three
sizes too small but i'm like nah they're
good they're good
i was trying to get patrick ewing from
georgetown that's what i was trying to
do yeah the
patrick ewings the old ones people those
were ugly though
yeah i remember my cousins who who were
like seven years older than me they
played
division three college basketball and
like they were big into high school
basketball yeah and then having like the
converse and stuff like that
yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah it started really
that it started in the 80s with like
those converse and like the mchales and
people that's when people started
getting into it
and then the jordans that was the game
changer yeah jordan once put it and then
the twos threes and then the threes were
huge and it was just like yeah
so you have a pretty sick sneaker
collection i do but the thing is
i'm not vast like a lot of these i'm i'm
sensible
i'm not a i'm frugal okay so i i just i
i'm a greeks are like that we don't like
to spend crazy uh-huh so it's like uh
but i have spent a lot on sneakers five
hundred dollars a lot on yeah
so i don't have a lot but i got good one
i got a nice
i got the ones i like i like and i keep
buying them every year i don't i don't
venture out yeah yeah you got a
wheelhouse that you stay in we're in the
95s right now i got like
17 pairs of these in different colors
that's crazy yeah what the
[ __ ] yeah just yeah dude i i know that
version is also a sneaker head yeah i
imagine you guys with like a scotch
and a cigar and a piece of steak and
you're in the closet like look i got the
tom force he's never blew him
off yeah first he's funny too he'll like
wipe him
he he'll walk a certain way so they
don't crease oh yeah i'm like that's
going too far man he'll walk like this
he waddles a little
i would imagine his house is impeccably
clean
his house is pretty clean impeccable his
wife uh she runs [ __ ] she's the best
yeah she right yeah she's great she's
[ __ ] the best
ah good stuff all right you guys are
searching for trash you're not finding
it that much
there's not much i'm a pretty clueless
kid
[ __ ] classy new york kid on our hands
right here i don't know what the [ __ ] to
do he's got [ __ ]
thousand dollars but he haggled him down
to 500. i don't know what the [ __ ] she
moved
you're haggling over a pair of shoes um
okay do you currently only own any boot
cut jeans wow you you're philly really
[ __ ]
like your zipper came out here
[Laughter]
dude my cousins dropped diet cute so bad
just get me a fountain cook from
mcdonald's
saudis yeah uh do you want any do you
own any boot cut jeans
no okay no no have you ever ordered a
red stripe beer
yeah yeah have you ever recommended a
book to somebody that you didn't read
but said you read because i make my
living doing that [ __ ]
um no i don't think i've done that okay
i got to be honest
when you lived in the city would you was
ever a doorman situation do you ever
have a doorman when you guys lived in
the city no maybe towards the end you
and your girl
no we never lived in i've always lived
in brooklyn i've always lived in pokemon
uh what i was getting at is i'm curious
who if anybody do you break off for
christmas
do you do you like holidays who do you
break off a little bit of cash nobody
nobody yeah and here's even worse greece
keep it tight i don't
order anything but water's in the green
room i don't tip
chris chris got mad at me
because chris like likes to you know he
grew up with all the union guys so he
like throws everybody
yeah everybody gets a dumb everybody
gets like you're a cheap [ __ ] he got mad
at me
i was like i didn't order anything isn't
that how that works oh my god you gotta
leave a dollar
if you're a high school kid in a [ __ ]
ponderosa i mean all i tried was like
that
only thing i drink was water you gotta
break i had a couple of waters where
they did sani or feet but fuji's are
here's the thing
like whoever else is there opener host
whatever they order they tip and
you know i didn't so they ate i didn't
eat the headliner you're doing it
i know breaking off at 20. that's what i
heard that's why i think i'm wrong
i'm probably wrong but i mean we're not
making that much [ __ ] money they're
making more money than me for a week
for a whole [ __ ] weekend they've made
more money than me
that doesn't matter you're so [ __ ]
out of control that's commie talk i
don't like that
why don't i we need to pass a [ __ ]
bucket around with the [ __ ] [ __ ] they
pass and then they send us the wtu
scumbags
and i called it a wt yeah i know what
you meant yeah you know what i mean
it's okay they put five waters on there
i mean you ever think about what these
waitresses make in the club and then
they got the [ __ ] balls to talk
like and be in a bad mood like you're
the one you should sit down with them be
like
it doesn't matter per se it doesn't
matter you got it you got to break off
it should be
come on it should be standing standard
operating procedure to have bottles of
water
in the green room sure so what am i
tipping them for for they're
for making more money yes they're making
a lot of money that's the thing they
make a lot of money
uh you're not wrong you're honest you
are not wrong i'm saying you're wrong
and it's not they don't have to pay
taxes on it it's cash
if you were a waitress at a comedy club
and you're doing four shows a night or
three four
years you're doing well but they're you
worked in the service industry yeah
you're like
soda used to give you a hard time about
this you're cheap [ __ ] yeah
i was like how much did you make they
they always go like yeah i have five
seven hundred dollars cash yeah i walk
with it i gotta
make an atm machine yeah i'll tip you
but i mean let's not whenever you go to
dinner with soda or soda would go like
here's a hundred and he's like you don't
know what they're going through i'm like
but
they [ __ ] took our order and then
mexicans came and did everything else
that's not true at all but shout out to
the guys in the kitchen
[ __ ] love yous i'm surprised you
never worked never did never did never
did i worked uh
too busy getting high with his good time
buddies yeah i did social work for five
years that was when i started doing
comedy
and uh night club i used to work at my
dad's office
every every year every summer all summer
i work at my dad's office there's greeks
that's what they do
you work come work for me yeah child
labor you keep it in a family yeah yeah
he could have been in a diner just as
easily though yeah he could have been
his dad actually you could have been you
could i could have seen yeah but his dad
actually got mad at him
for wanting to go to college he didn't
understand that yeah like what are you
gonna do yeah
see i saw that as the american dream
like the you know an immigrant comes
here they bust their ass and then they
want their kids to be college educated
not greeks they're like well you're
going to live home
take the business what's the problem
who's going to finish
the whole family works here whatever you
you know and greeks trust nobody you
know
when you you can't hand the check to the
waiter you got to walk it up to his 80
year old wife
and the cash
yeah they're paranoid people greeks yeah
though hell of a [ __ ] eye i mean the
diner
the 24-hour diner is there anything
greater i love it as a comedian
and that's the thing going back to
[ __ ] always wanting to live here
there is
nothing that can compare to that to know
that
for me knowing that times square is
always lit up
is something and knowing that there's
always a [ __ ] diner where [ __ ] people
are ordering
full meals at 3x soup salad bread on the
table yeah yeah
[ __ ] meatloaf two [ __ ] socks
whatever you want come on yeah whatever
you want
eggs at night anything exit night going
and all [ __ ] up and getting like an
omelette with yeah it's the best it's
the best i do tip i don't want you to
think i don't tip i tip 20
okay okay when i order something
i don't just walk around and hand people
people you're hanging people
20 i'm not backing down from this if i
don't order anything why am i tipping
it makes sense you're not wrong you are
not wrong but he's not on board
no no he's not she's servicing the room
and she's not asking she i'm not asking
her
she's she's getting compensated for the
services she provides for the for
other people who ordered she's getting
tips on that it's not wrong and here's
the thing a lot of times when they're
not right
not right right but it's not wrong he
just summed it up yeah i'm trash for it
yeah
but i'm not i don't love it yanny but i
can still argue my way out it'll hold up
in court
but just think about this just think
about this if she got that section
yeah having the green room section might
take away from other tables that she
might have
right so she could already be starting
off on a load too
and she sees you on the billboard she's
like called in sick i got the rona
johnny p's headlining but if i do order
i tip big
nice so i tip big okay okay okay so now
i know i'm
to tip somebody for a job they didn't do
for me that's what it is
[ __ ] waiters are there's most
sympathy for anyone in this country is
waiters
that's why he's leaning right yeah he's
out in the verbs he's not tipping i like
get away from my money if you come on my
property i'll shoot you you goddamn
libby i live in the suburbs now get off
my goddamn property
that's great i was at governor's one
time and uh i ordered a beer and they
stole
another guy next to me and i was working
and uh the guy next to me
dropped a tea paid and then dropped the
20 as a tip and he left yeah
and the other the the bartender came up
and thought it was mine he goes oh
thanks man thank you so much
and i didn't tell him it wasn't mine you
piece of [ __ ] i was just kind of like
all right
smart move dude
i was getting [ __ ] off menu you don't
want him to enjoy that moment it happens
once in a lifetime yeah
if you're tough to be honest come on
it's like you walk in
like he was only going to get a dollar
from me you know what i mean if you walk
into a place
and you have the same name as like
somebody and the guy just thinks
that's you mm-hmm you're gonna tell him
if he's treating you
yeah or are you just not right this way
mr foley you're gonna go i'll see what's
going on are you the guy that has the
app
you're going to go no it's not me here's
the dollar give me a pbr
whoa eddie murphy hey good to see you
man
what's up jack you got to keep it going
you know
that's [ __ ] all right let's we got a
couple more and then we gotta go we
gotta get out of here
yeah we gotta go yeah thank you so much
we've been running long you guys are
philly trash
oh i would stay here all day long
we're getting you and an eagle's hat i'm
[ __ ] like i'm gonna fill it well when
i said own yes like what he stopped me
mid question
because someone was like your dick was
out you know i was like tip it off
[Music]
there is with three great what do you
think's the trashiest accent of all in
america
chicago boston philly south southern
i would say uh boston it's vacuum it's
pretty bad i think baltimore baltimore's
a grimier philly
baltimore is a good one too yeah that
mid-atlantic yeah philly's up there
because philly has that you have this
you feel even when you speak it yeah you
feel
like even if you if you if you use the
accent as well when you hear it
you feel sick to your stomach a little
bit yeah and like it doesn't matter what
like my niece i got i got a six-year-old
niece she's coming out of a cute
she's gorgeous she's beautiful she's fun
she's outgoing
but when she says can i have a say that
dude
i just want to throw up yeah yes
maybe philly maybe philly baltimore
florida's bad
higgins drinking the [ __ ] i want to
shoot him
yeah that is weird coming out of a
child's face you're like
you should be more innocent but the
midwestern too when when an adult woman
has that you know
oh hey how are you there shitty
yeah if you have a heavy accent you're
trash well that's like i mean new york's
the same as phil is where the outside of
the set like center people in center
city philadelphia don't really have an
accent right i mean like right
same with manhattan really for the most
part schultz doesn't have an accident
about staten island uh you know the long
island
they all they're the ones with the
accent that's where it gets trashy yeah
i was mad about that we went to boston
uh a couple years ago just for like a
little a little getaway
um and stayed like in boston proper and
like the whole weekend that's like i'm
talking about that's all rich that's all
yeah yeah
the whole weekend i'm getting nothing
i'm getting [ __ ] ripped off here yeah
i paid for the [ __ ] experience you
wanna you wanna be in the town that's
right
billy blobby tommy johnny for all that
[ __ ] and it wasn't until we got on their
their subway or the [ __ ] they call that
thing up there it's
terrible was there was some something
trained
yeah lady that was like a deuce and a
quarter [ __ ] running it yeah
smoking in newport goodwill hunting's
mom yeah
mrs hunting i want to see that movie
above goodwill hunting's parents yeah
he was we didn't know what to do with
him he's gay he was good at sticks yeah
we told him get the [ __ ] out of here
you're not gonna do iron work or
whatever yeah
yeah uh i love it all right i got one or
two from patreon guys as you know when
you join patreon we will answer your
questions it's
that's the only way to do it we get so
many requests from everybody else
we love you so much for the support
thank you also [ __ ] patreon's cooking
thanks
everybody that joined is [ __ ]
fantastic uh this is from nick
uh do you put the twist tie back on the
bread or do you twist it and fold it
over and leave it there i twisted and
folded it yeah
you do kitty's trash
sometimes i won't get a plate and i'll
use the plastic as the plate with the
bread and put it on that whatever
plastic is there
however bread i'm down and however
prastic is there to make
dude that is savage this guy's this
guy's making [ __ ]
making a sandwich on the bread bag and
not tipping
crazy this guy's out of control you got
to be stopped this is like a game where
i came in hunt you guys i don't know
pretty classy and at the end
like wow it's tom brady in the fourth
quarter baby
it's [ __ ] garbage time dude yeah it's
garbage time yeah who's doing the
shopping up there
oh my wife does your wife does it yeah
yeah um are you guys a lunch meat family
yeah so you're making sure you got the
whole thing set up i can't lay off
bologna
really big bologna guy wow i know how
bad it is for you and everything
wait hold on is she getting baloney from
the counter or like from the pre-package
no she gets from the
if you get it from the pre-package oh
dude hold on whatever if someone says
they get it
i didn't know they said kick them off
the show say you're trashing you don't
need to do the job yeah you got sliced
bologna from the deli counter like a
[ __ ] gentleman
oh i've been eating oscar maya like a
jerk off yeah
that's [ __ ] true i didn't even know
they had it back wow
you didn't even know that that's how
that's a little trash i didn't know
existed i'm looking at you like
that means his grandparents are trapped
yeah i thought it was just for fancy
stuff like ham and turkey and buffalo
chicken meat
i feel like
you're doing blazing buffalo roll-ups
and then you feel good because there's
no
right like this is low you eat 15 pounds
of lunch yeah [ __ ]
so good you ate 14 000 uh
milligrams of sodium yeah it's coming
out your pores before you're even done
eating it
the [ __ ] all right get some regular
chicken if you have the option for
blazing buffalo
who doesn't get that who doesn't get it
[ __ ] jerkless
who goes no no give me the unflavored
chicken
i don't know what they're putting in it
but that [ __ ] is [ __ ] on point
does that i like a little cream and
sugar in my car i don't know about you
folks
please and buffalo me uh options there
it's just always strange to me that
someone wouldn't take it
what's the um you got your mayonnaise
family
i love mayonnaise okay no no no i ha
like uh hold on don't say anything
cause this is big okay is it miracle
whip or is it mayonnaise no hellman's
mayonnaise
okay nice this is how much mayonnaise i
like uh in college
i i was a lifeguard in college that's
why i didn't i stayed in dc during the
summers and i worked at a pool
nice and we did pool operated but we
also worked at health club we'd go
to blimpies to get sandwiches and i
would say i would always say heavy on
the mayo
right this is how much i like mayo they
would never put as much as i like
so i had to figure out a way to tell
them how much i wanted it you wanted
more
so this is what i would say everywhere i
went because this is what you're having
a little bit
system i had a plenty system and if you
like a lot of mayo
here's and you're trying to figure out
how to explain it and you're in a
blimpies for some reason
yeah or wawa's and it says more mayo and
that's not what is that's not going to
cut it
you got to talk to the woman you say
this is what you say offend me with the
mayonnaise
[Laughter]
they get it that makes them get it
offend me
with and i would say that to them
every time that's how much i love mayo
my sandwich offend me with the
mayonnaise
jeez and they look at me and then that
thing comes [ __ ]
dripping in white sauce that's the way i
like to do it
i don't yeah you were on the fence
before but i mean you got [ __ ] you
got hacks at blimpies that's crazy
buddha [ __ ] did blimpies to no
[ __ ] tricks in a trade
i bet you she gets a 20 huh right across
the [ __ ] counter
offend me with the mayonnaise
it works i'm telling you if you if you
want to go heavy just tell them to
offend you
what do you like you like a lot of sauce
on something right like a lot of sauce
on a lot of things and usually it comes
not as much as you want it right
hollandaise sauce and
grenade sauce is big with me so tell him
i'm offended i've never gotten enough
we need to get him off the sauces by the
way okay we don't need him ordering
extra extra anything
i've never got enough [ __ ]
hollandaise sauce in my life
by the looks of you you have
not that special of a sauce if anything
they're a little heavy-handed
yeah um okay have you ever used
disposable uh this is i'm sorry one more
and then we'll
uh we'll wrap it up this is from dave uh
no i'm sorry this is from chris
does your family eat holiday meals with
disposable plates and utensils
my wife's family does and i eat with
them now but my family never did
hmm yeah what's her background uh she's
greek and
italian greek and sicilian and they
they're from long island
they're from long island but the food's
top shelf food's good
is that long island that's really good
okay yeah food's really top shelf
what do you mean by top shelf he's not
he's not they're not you're not selling
it that hard as well what do you mean
like
what her mother cooks is it is it is it
so good that it's over the paper plates
are overlooked because that's a big
thing if
it's if it's mediocre food on paper
plates
i'm going to someone else's house and
you can overlook it great food we don't
they don't recycle we don't i now i
don't cause i i'm you know i
you're in the bus i'm in the country
yeah yeah
throw it in the in the in the fireplace
it goes in the fireplace really yeah all
the paper plates go in the fireplace so
do uh cardboard boxes is that bad wait
what do you
wait so hold on you eat you'll eat
thanksgiving dinner then go throw those
dishes in the [ __ ] you know that holy
[ __ ] is [ __ ] up that's i don't know
wait a minute that's not even laughable
that's insane
yeah your hat your house now has a
fireplace yeah it's inside fireplace not
like a fire pit out in the ground
he's so new york he thinks it's an
incinerator yeah he's burning [ __ ] in
his living room
are you [ __ ] old he's throwing like
that dead dog in there and [ __ ]
that's not bad it's bad to throw a it's
paper you put it in the fireplace you
shouldn't be burning trash in your
living room
no no why that's one i don't think it's
[ __ ] medically like
you'll be you're an inhaler you can't be
breathing dixie fumes [ __ ] in your we
got to stop doing that
i learned it from them and now i do it
that's bad that's good
you'll be sitting there let's just say
you're sitting there eating something
let's clean it up now
what are your hobos [ __ ] trying to
keep warm that's i never
felt bad about it to you guys and now
you guys are making a lot of sense wait
wait like get a lot of sense what's up
what's up you know you don't know it's
weird till you step outside of yourself
how how much do you scrape the plates
it's not a clear you're putting like i
don't know
whatever just goes in yeah are you
[ __ ] like garbage yeah it gets burnt
up yeah
boxes too everything old rugs
old cribs dogs
i mean you know what if your dog dies
you just put it in the fire
dead i mean dude this isn't you're
joking right now oh i'm if you have a
death i know how bad that's gonna smell
it's not gonna smell that bad yeah it's
not gonna smell good it's gonna smell
like
meat like when you cook meat no it's not
i i'm a dog lover so people are looking
tomato on that one huh
like if your dog dies why don't you
insinua why don't you
you know because those don't get up to
that kind of [ __ ] temperature yeah
like offend me with the barbecue yeah oh
my god i didn't know that
i didn't know that that's why i asked
the question don't judge don't tell your
neighbors that yeah
let mersey find out you're burning your
trash and you're living versy didn't
give you to run down to how to act out
in the suburbs when you got out there
you don't do that
all right so that okay all right well i
mean that's all i needed to know you
can't come back
you can't come back from there yeah i
mean i started strong and now we're in
what about
what about the depths of trash what
about the plastic forks and [ __ ] like
that no those get uh
he's not an animal yeah i mean come on
put them in the tub
yeah you got a shower you got bleach
soaking it up
we we wash them and reuse those no
really no i'm kidding my mom
my mom has a my mom has levels of
plastic silverware
and there is one level that looks metal
but it's actually plastic
that gets re-washed and yeah my mom
growing up
growing up under occupation my mom would
reuse paper towels
oh i would hang them and drive this the
nazi regime you know what i mean this
isn't the suburbs yeah surprised they
had paper towels and
nazi occupations she does that now oh
she does that now from
immigration well immigrants have that
mentality yeah that's immigration i
couldn't see
it's like this is america america yeah
seeing like wet paper towels hanging
like their clothes yeah
yeah it's weird that's kind of like a
mental illness like that just let you
know your trauma sticks with you
sure yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure um all
right well i've i have all the
information i need at this point to
render a verdict uh
the man is trash the man is [ __ ]
trash
sharp dresser i'll give you that you got
a nice you wear a nice hoodie i dress it
up but it's trash underneath yeah yeah
yeah
it's pig with lipstick still water's
running thanksgiving dinner in your
fireplace i thought that was okay i
thought everybody did that no
i just did somebody that's somebody
who's i've only ever been on the l train
[Laughter]
so this is a lipstick with a pig
situation yeah yeah you look good on the
surface
you need some local campaign signs in
your front lawn and you need a good
landscape right you need to stop you
need like jim mckinney for comptroller
exactly that's a respectable suburbian
and behavior
you cook out in the backyard not in the
front right right
right are you gonna get a pool you
thinking about a pool no
no no pool pools are just insurance
nightmares
that's me knowing that's classy right
i'll give you that
that's suburbs one-on-one yeah insurance
who is cutting the grass i think you've
got a landscaper are you doing it
yeah you got a guy yeah it's half the
season right what is it 60 bucks a week
yeah yeah it's not splitting it up yeah
you're interested in getting your own
lawn mower and doing
doing it no city kid i don't even know
how do you do that him on a johnny
wouldn't look good
put that on the bay ridge boy's patreon
yanni cuts his grass
on fire yeah i don't know how to do any
of that [ __ ] i don't know how to take
care of plants or
i just come up with a a cup full of
water and pour it on something
yeah that's all i do yeah
[Laughter]
i give it a doc browns every once in a
while when uh when food goes bad is this
tra
this is what i do in the country now i
take the food and throw it in the
backyard
i'm not against it yeah uh like what
kind of food we talk in like an apple or
like
apples or like a pork loin anything that
like is gonna be a problem it's gonna
if garbage day's friday and it's gonna
smell and it's monday it's gonna smell
i'll just throw it in the yard how far
back as far as i can i got it
i got an anchor sometimes i'll walk it
to the back but you throw it into the
tree line not on the lawn
no sometimes that's a lot but sometimes
the banana peels yeah they're close
because those those eventually are gonna
melt into the ground yeah like a year
your landscape you're still gonna step
on that [ __ ]
when he's cutting the [ __ ] grass for
half the rate and no dip
problem he's probably gonna slip break
an arm now your insurance goes up you
agreed to it
in case you agree you're just hooking
food hoping a raccoon shows up so you
can feel at home yeah but
it's stupid because the deer is coming
they bring ticks i'm learning
yeah throwing the loaf of bread out
there yeah it's essentially what it is
this was uh this was something else this
was awesome this was so much fun
we love you yeah yeah yeah big fan i
love you 100
i learned something we got to the bottom
of it together yeah sort of like just
therapeutic it's kind of like therapy
where you just you take a good hard look
at yourself and you realize
these behaviors are not right no no no
they're uncouth
i knew it was turning but i didn't say
anything you knew it was turning at the
tip how you got into college
when i when i knew that and that's where
your brain was going i'm like this guy's
got dirt under his face yeah
yeah true story you can google that it's
funny and the kids he's still a popular
professor
really yeah still kept his clout a
little bit tenured you could do anything
if you have tenure
yeah that's why he's [ __ ] these
teachers every dirtbag i know that's
like
ten years yeah tenure
[Laughter]
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] anymore yeah
damn do your homework who gives a [ __ ]
go oh my god
we got that anything uh you want the
folks out there to know that they might
not already know what do you got uh
obviously history hyenas anything you
want to plug anything you want to
mention
no you guys nailed it yeah i know you
they love you yeah long days podcast new
it's my solo podcast where uh we just go
and uh the history hyenas podcast and um
check my special please blow in the
light
yeah check it out something's free on
youtube yeah yeah absolutely fantastic
follow me on instagram giannis there you
go sorry oh no it's awesome
uh guys thanks so much for listening uh
chevron comedy on all social media
as i said before please make sure you
rate review subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube those numbers
are through the roof
and [ __ ] patreon guys we appreciate
it so much thanks for the support
peace we love you guys we'll see you
next week peace
that was [ __ ] fun something else
who's built this for you
we did it all you did yeah yeah